[Music]
former today show co-host katie couric
released a tell-all book recently called
going there in it she reveals that she
once intentionally left out a quote from
supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg out of an interview a quote
where ginsburg said
football players kneeling for the
national anthem have contempt for a
government that has made it possible for
their parents and grandparents to live a
decent life
y'all
when i heard this i felt conflicted now
on one hand she has done so much but
on the other hand that's some old
[ __ ]
now i knew i had to take this to the
only place real justice is served
the my people's court
hear he hear ye the my people's court is
now in session the honorable judge
ruffin presided
settle down
settle down everyone
order order i will have order
today we will hear the case of rbg is
still cool versus rbg is no longer cool
this trial will determine how i think
about her for years to come it's time
for opening arguments corrine thank you
your honor
supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg changed america she spent her
entire career advocating for gender
equality and women's rights dare i say
her hard work has made your hard work
possible
you make a good point jeff
contempt for a government that has made
it possible for their parents and
grandparents to live a decent life
come on now
well
that's a good point your honor this
woman co-founded the women's rights
project at aclu she publicly denounced
trump she achieved a lot and one comment
cannot erase all the good she's done for
this country
one comment shoot that was one hell of a
comment
come on now
yeah
that's a good point
it's true well ginsburg was the first
justice to officiate a same-sex marriage
come on nah she advocated for the
separation of church and state come on
here's a picture of her hugging barack
obama
come on now
your honor her dying wish was to not be
replaced on the supreme court so
conservatives wouldn't gain a majority
and roll back women's rights that means
on her death bed she was thinking of
your future
that's a good point
your honor may i approach the bench you
may
come on now overruled it's overruled i'm
sorry come on
argue with come on
jeff is acting like this oh you're under
there
all right
i will have order in this court yeah
don't make me come over there sorry
sorry your honor
well it's time for me to decide corrine
you made some good points and jeff i'm a
big fan
but
i'm still lost i still don't know how to
think of rbg
your honor
is it possible that the error here is in
turning an ancient white lady into a
hero and expecting her to have a squeaky
clean record to expect a white lady who
was born in 1933
in these here united states of america
to be perfectly unproblematic
can't you just admit she did a lot but
was pretty racist but probably less
racist than every other person her age
hmm
come on man he's right the court finds
me guilty of holding an ancient white
lady to unrealistic
this concludes this edition of the my
people's court
[Music]
the my people's court
[Applause]
[Music]
you